season all right let's talk more sports
we go to the ice last night look
at this vegas golden knights evened up
their first round playoff series with
minnesota at t-mobile
the wild did open the scoring but vegas
scored three unanswered goals to take
the win
as you see here 8 600 fans packed the
fortress and they were
reasonably pleased with the win magical
bringing vegas back to what vegas has
always normally been
either regular season hockey or playoff
hockey
the whole crowd got fired up again and
from that point on we rolled
this was like pre-covered energy
and everything else like wins our first
game back
and before the you know the whole
pandemic and
it was absolutely everything we
remembered and we're like
oh amazing absolutely amazing even more
yeah even more all right well the vegas
golden knights are now heading on the
road they'll be in minnesota for the
next two games in the playoff series
tomorrow and saturday
and of course the eight news now sports
team will have live coverage from the
games
which are in st paul in the twin cities
go knights go